[Musique]
il est un peu moins de minuit lorsque un
par un les enfants se retrouve à l'air
libre trempés mais sains et saufs le
premier geste des sauveteurs et de leur
donner du chocolat chaud et des
couvertures avant de les emmener à pied
un peu plus bas jusqu'au village où les
parents attendent regroupés dans une
salle du théâtre au total ce sont 22
collégiens âgés de 12 à 13 ans et 3
adultes que les sauveteurs ont dû
évacuer le plus rapidement possible on
leur équipe et avec des boules riez les
cordes étaient au plafond et il y
restait deux petits passages un peu un
peu délicat mais qu'on pouvait passer en
sécurité encadrée avec deux sauveteurs
part par enfant c'est ce qu'on a fait
pour pour permettre une sortie quand
même un peu plus rapide et pas attendre
la fin totale de la crue
c'est ici que les enfants se sont
retrouvés coincés par la brusque montée
des eaux pour rejoindre la sorte il leur
a fallu avec l'aide des sauveteurs
traverser ce boyau presque totalement
inondées on a équipé en main courante et
on a mis une corde il va aider à
progresser assurer cette progression
tout au long au pur et dur de la décrue
et c'est ça qui a été le plus difficile
avec de ressaut vraiment y ait beaucoup
d'eau beaucoup de passion donc très
difficile à passer
et puis aussi rassuré il y avait des
gens qui nous rassure et
voilà on est en devoir en plus on avait
peur il avait froid la vapeur on est
tous qu'il fallait pas on se disait
aussi qu'avec un beaucoup de gens qui
étaient autour et qui m'a qui étaient là
pour nous aider en fait il y avait des
profs y avait des directeurs y avait de
ce directeur
de koné t'es pas tout seul en fait à une
heure ce matin la longue journée
d'angoissé qui aurait pu tourner au
drame s'achève bien selon les anciens du
pays il n'y avait pas eu de promeneurs
piégées par les eaux dans ces grottes
depuis 1965
[Musique]